es war kanzleramtsminister helge braun
der heute klar stellte mindestens bis
zum zwanzigsten april liegt deutschland
im kampf gegen die korona pandemie auch
große teile der wirtschaft lahm
ein anderes mittel hat die politik
derzeit nicht und doch muss sie wie bei
jeder therapie risiken und
nebenwirkungen bedenken kann der punkt
kommen wo die virus bekämpfung mehr
schaden mehr elend schafft als die
krankheit selbst das ist eine wichtige
frage und keine die sich leicht
beantworten lässt
gesunde menschen sind die basis für eine
florierende wirtschaft klar muss man
nicht dennoch exit strategien suchen was
coroner für unsere wirtschaft die
arbeitsplätze und für die gesellschaft
bedeutet darüber wollen wir heute reden
mit diesen gesten oder scholz
bundesfinanzminister und vizekanzler
der unternehmer karl häuschen
gabor steingart journalist und autor
der textileinzelhändler harald heldmann
zugeschaltet aus hamburg gabriel
felbermayr präsident des instituts für
weltwirtschaft und sahra wagenknecht
bundestagsabgeordnete der linken
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die begrüßt sie noch mal sehr herzlich
in der runde
los geht's ihre zuschauer mit der
schlichten feststellung corona macht
menschen krank aber auch unternehmen
es bleibt gespenstisch mindestens bis
zum zwanzigsten april
danach könnte es brutal werden
entscheidungen müssen hier für die
wirtschaft manche drücken aufs tempo
nur tage nach der vollbremsung eins ist
klar so ein zustand wie jetzt können uns
einige wochen erlauben auch leisten
natürlich geht gesundheit vor aber wir
können uns das nicht drei vier fünf
sechs monate leisten wenn man über einen
ausstieg nachdenkt ist es wichtig dass
man eine klare strategie hat und das
sehr frühzeitig auch an die wirtschaft
kommuniziert die frage zwischen den
seilen welche langfristigen schäden an
wirtschaft und wohlstand nehmen wir in
kauf für viele menschen leben die in den
nächsten wochen und monaten gerettet
werden gerettet werden weil alles
stillsteht und hoffentlich die kurve
abflacht
das kieler ifw rechnet mit einem
einbruch bis zu neun prozent
das ifo institut kommt im worst case k
auf minus 20 prozent ein fünftel unseres
bruttoinlandsprodukts
doch was einbricht kann auch wieder hoch
schießen variante v die wirtschaft
stürzt ab und erholt sich schnell wieder
eine voraussetzung die ganze welt macht
das v
denn wenn nicht wem wollte deutschland
danach welche produkte verkaufen
der albtraum variante die wirtschaft
stürzt ab braucht aber viele jahre um
sich zu erholen
die folge massenarbeitslosigkeit armut
leere staatskassen und eine schlechtere
gesundheitsversorgung bei egal welcher
krankheit
bayerns ist gabor steingart journalist
und autor
herr steigert das die heilung schlimmer
sein könnte als die krankheit fürchtet
nicht nur dort trank tee auch das hängt
davon ab wie lange dieser zustand da und
ich glaube man kann auf dauer gesundheit
gegen wirtschaft nicht ausspielen weil
für diese first class medizin die wir
jetzt erwarten viele sogar mehr davon
erwarten kann man nicht die wirtschaft
auf null schalten und sie ist ja nicht
nur auf null geschaltet sondern sie wird
jetzt runter fallen 35 milliarden
ungefähr pro woche verlieren wir an
wertschöpfung dass es viel und wenn sich
das zieht wird es dramatisch ich glaube
im moment ist die entscheidung richtig
und auch verkraftbar
der film hat gezeigt es gibt auch ein
leben danach der zustand darf nur nicht
ewig dauern deswegen reden wir glaube
ich ja heute darüber wie man auch wieder
rauskommt sie schreiben von einer angst
erzählung und man wahrscheinlich
panikmache hatte man corona nicht doch
eher unterschätzt
ich glaube zunächst haben die experten
unterschätzt trotzdem glaube ich schon
auch das in der öffentlichkeit und auch
medial eine eine übertreibung wie das
üblich ist bei vielen themen stattfindet
übertreibung insofern als dass die
zahlen zwar hoch sind und natürlich
schrecklich sind trotzdem in ein
relativiert müssen untersagt mit mit
habermas vergleichen heißt nicht
gleichsetzen wenn man vergleicht die
nikotin toten
die herzen faktoren auch die selbstmorde
in deutschland fast zehntausend dann
muss man das in einem verhältnis rücken
zumindest wenn man über die ökonomie der
gegenmaßnahmen auch spricht und deshalb
bergamo mahnte red bull los das ist
nicht nur eine erzählerin ist
erschreckend natürlich so erschreckend
vor allem auch wie schlecht man die
länder einfach vorbereitet sind und dann
wieder beruhigend wie gut deutschland
mit intensivbetten zum beispiel hier auf
diese krise tatsächlich vorbereitet sind
wir haben kapazität deutschland ist
nicht bergamo muss man ganz klar sagen
das wäre teil der angst erzählung wenn
wir so tun als ob italien hier vor der
tür steht bei uns in so viele betten
frei wie in italien insgesamt zur
verfügung stehen
genau aber wir wollen eben vorbereitet
sein weil es tatsächlich jeden treffen
kann irgendwie dieses virus noch nicht
gut kennen die kanzlerin findet gut ich
zitiere olaf scholz ist bei uns der
bundesfinanzminister findet nicht gut
jetzt schon über locker
moments versprechen armin laschet der
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen will zumindest
nachdenken dürfen nachdenken ohne zu
sprechen geben dass in einer demokratie
wenn er die kanzlerin hat recht wir
haben vor wenigen tagen entschieden dass
wir viele bereiche des sozialen lebens
reduzieren dass wir haben entschieden
dass man im öffentlichen raum sich zwar
bewegen kann aber eben nicht in großen
gruppen und gerade wo das passiert ist
fängt es dann an dass die ersten sich
darüber gedanken machen wann das alles
wieder zu ende geht für uns ist doch
eigentlich ganz klar wann das wieder zu
ende geht wir müssen eine abflachung der
kurve der ansteckung erreichen damit wir
sicher sein können dass unsere
medizinischen kapazitäten mit der zahl
derjenigen die eine intensive betreuung
brauchen zusammenpassen
das machen wir indem wir einerseits
diese kapazitäten die schon hoch sind
weiter erhöhen indem wir priorisierung
vornehmen dafür sorgen dass unsere
krankenhäuser sich sehr auf diesen fall
konzentrieren können neben denen
notoperation maßnahmen die sonst noch
nötig sind und gleichzeitig versuchen
wir eben durch die entscheidungen die
getroffen sind dafür zu tragen dafür zu
sorgen dass das nicht mehr so viele sind
die sich anstecken wie es wäre wenn wir
es wenn wir gar nichts täten und die
bilder und die berichte die wir aus
anderen ländern sehen und hören auch
ländern die gar nichts gemacht haben und
der meinung waren man müsste auch nichts
machen die sind ja erschreckend das soll
uns nicht passieren wir reden gleich
noch darüber wie eben die maßnahmen
aussehen und wie sie vor allen dingen
kleinen mittelständischen und großen
unternehmen helfen in der wirtschaft
ohne natürlich aus dem blick zu
verlieren
dass wir wir sind bei karl häuschen in
einem gesundheitssystem leben das auf
das größte vorbereitet sein muss sie
sind vizepräsident des vdm
das ist der verband der deutschen
maschinen- und anlagenführer sie sind
selber unternehmer
die wirtschaft bricht zusammen
weltwirtschaft bricht in teilen zusammen
bauen die autobauer in deutschland noch
wie sieht es in der branche ausbauen sie
noch das unternehmen harry traurig dass
ich vertrete baut im augenblick noch wir
sind eines der unternehmen die auf
vernetzte wertschöpfungsketten
angewiesen sind
jeder betrieb der schließt kann dafür
sorgen dass wir unseren betrieb
schließen müssen um das ist der erste
hinweis vielleicht darauf wie wichtig es
ist dass zumindest der produzierenden
industrie so wenig wie möglich schließen
wir sind meines erachtens mit mit drei
handlungsfeldern hier konfrontiert wir
haben das sehr wichtige und sehr
dringende handlungsfeld gesundheit
wir haben das genau so wichtige zu
diesem zeitpunkt aber nicht ganz so
dringende handlungsfeld wirtschaft und
wohlstand und wir haben das in diesem
augenblick vielleicht nicht so dringend
aber genauso wichtiges handlungsfeld
welche freiheiten welche demokratischen
gepflogenheiten die wir uns erarbeitet
haben wir in dieser krise zur
disposition stellen
und ich glaube man wird alle maßnahmen
zwischen diesen drei handlungsfeldern
abwägen müssen nochmals für ihren
lieferanten arbeiten ihre
niederlassungen in china noch haben sie
praktisch für die maschinen die sie
herstellen auch noch mit solider
industrie zur verfügung
der maschinenbau ist ja mit so die
exportorientierte branche
die wir in deutschland haben insofern wm
praktisch allen betroffenen
industrienationen aktiv unser betrieb in
china arbeitet wieder
wir hatten eine pause von vier wochen
wir haben knapp zahlen der mitarbeiter
in china von diesen zahlen der
mitarbeiter in etwa 90 prozent der
arbeit und arbeiten jeden tag wir haben
im kompletten unterbruch in italien das
ist kein wunder
in allen anderen ländern arbeiten wir
daran bank nicht es bei uns von der
linken frauen recht wer jetzt nach dem
folgen für die wirtschaft fragt muss der
gleichgültig sein gegenüber menschen
leben kann nicht auch eine
weltwirtschaftskrise sogar tote fordern
also nach den folgen muss man fragen und
zwar ein so weit dass die politik gegen
halb muss aber also unheimlich sind mir
schon die die jetzt schon wieder druck
machen möglichst bald die maßnahmen auf
zu heben weil ich muss sagen das was wir
wirklich aus anderen ländern sehen ob
das new york ist ob das italien ist dass
es so dramatisch und selbstverständlich
würden italienische zahlen auch das
deutsche gesundheitswesen völlig
überfordern ich meine man muss ja sehen
wir sind besser ausgestattet als die
italiener aber auch hier wurden ja in
den letzten jahren und jahrzehnten
massiv betten abgebaut wir haben
personalnotstand in den krankenhäusern
also wir müssen alles tun das zu
verhindern und ich glaube politisch muss
man jetzt vor allem eines tun man kann
nicht verhindern dass die wirtschaft
jetzt erst mal runter geht das ist ja
logisch wenn ganz viele bereiche einfach
nicht mehr stattfinden man muss
verhindern dass es ein massensterben
kleiner und mittlerer unternehmen gibt
weil das was weg ist also die
industriekapazitäten die wir verlieren
die sind dann auch nicht mehr da die
kommen auch nicht einfach mal wieder
oder die ladenlokale die kleinen
restaurants die die alle jetzt weggehen
die kaputtgehen
die sind dann eben auch weg das würde
die innenstädte verändern das würde das
gesamte leben in deutschland verändern
und ich glaube das ist jetzt die
entscheidende politische aufgabe alles
dafür zu tun dass dieser
wirtschaftseinbruch nicht dazu führt das
unternehmen sterben und da muss ich
ehrlich sagen finde ich die jetzigen
maßnahmen da ist ganz viel richtiges
dabei was die bundesregierung macht aber
sie sind gerade für kleine und mittlere
unternehmen überhaupt nicht ausreichen
werden wir euer man of kredite geht und
viele von diesen unternehmen bekommen
von ihrer hausbank den kredit einfach
nicht und auch gerade im moment nicht
ich begrüße einen fünften gast in dieser
sendung und zwar sehr herzlich gabriel
felbermayr nämlich vom institut für
weltwirtschaft in hamburg herr
felbermayr sie prophezeien die mutter
aller rezessionen auch dass eine angst
erzählung oder vielleicht eine
übertragung
ich hoffe dass das eine übertreibung ist
aber mittlerweile das ist ja schon so
aus als ob ein konsens gibt unter den
analysten dass die reduktion des
wirtschaftslebens die wir jetzt schon
haben dass die berufe ungefähr 35
euro kostet für die deutsche
volkswirtschaft und wenn wir das zwei
monate lang machen dann kann man schnell
hochskalieren welchen größenordnung wenn
wir landen es ist also eine tiefe
rezession mit der wir rechnen müssen
eine die nicht nur auf deutschland
beschränkt ist sondern die ganze welt
wird in eine rezession rutschen das
sieht mittlerweile auch der
internationale währungsfonds und was
auch noch mal außergewöhnlich ist es
sind wirklich alle wirtschaftsbereiche
die betroffenen sind mit ganz wenigen
ausnahmen wenn sie nicht einmal soll
heißen oder im medizintechnikbereich
tätig sind dann werden sie von dieser
rezession negativ betroffen und in dem
sinne ist es eine spezielle lage was
noch dazukommt ist dass die rezession
nicht aus einem zusammenbruch zum
beispiel von immobilienmärkten kommt
oder eine platzen einer blase wieder
sonst oft der fall ist bei rezessionen
sondern es ist eine behördlich
angeordnete teil abschaltung der
volkswirtschaft das macht das so einer
sehr speziellen lage in der wir heute
sind
herr scholz wie lange kann man firmen
künstliches koma dieser begriff ist
schon gefallen wie lange man kann immer
eine volkswirtschaft künstlich am leben
halten und wann müsste man wieder
anfangen zu öffnen
nach welchen kriterien wir haben uns
jedenfalls entschieden alles dafür zu
tun dass wir so lange durchhalten können
wie das notwendig ist um die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen bürger zu schützen und
dass es völlig richtig was frau
wagenknecht auch gesagt hat dass wir
jetzt dafür sorgen müssen dass die
unternehmen durch diese situation kommen
das haben wir gemacht mit sehr vielen
programmen aber eben auch mit einer sehr
entschiedene unterstützung durch den
bundeshaushalt sie wissen letzte woche
haben wir 156 milliarden euro
zusätzliche kredite möglich gemacht
haben außerdem haben wir haben außerdem
einen sehr großen schutzschirm
aufgespannt der dafür sorgen kann dass
wir uns an unternehmen mit eigenkapital
beteiligen können dass wir kredite
vergeben können und die kredite der
hausbanken bis zu 90 prozent garantieren
können was alles zusammen dazu beitragen
soll dass möglichst viele durchhalten
und das können wir länger als das
gegenwärtig geplant ist möglich machen
aber trotzdem komme ich zurück die erste
frage die wir beantworten müssen sind
müssen ist sind wir soweit dass wir
erkennen können dass sich die infektion
abgeflachten haben und das sich an geld
jetzt vorlegen würde nach der rechnung
von herrn felbermayr grob geschätzt für
fünf monate reichen
und dennoch denken jetzt natürlich gabor
steingart menschen darüber nach wie man
das handhaben kann also dass wir all die
dinge nicht mehr machen die spaß machen
fußballspiele in europa das haben wir
auch alle verstanden die dinge die aber
sein müssen arbeit schule werden
irgendwann wieder möglich gemacht und
bedingt ich glaube und deswegen muss man
die diskussion vielleicht da geb ich dir
recht nicht im fernsehstudio aber die
eine regierung wenn sie ich meine wir
waren nicht vorbereitet auf das ding
kann man vielleicht nicht sein wer hat
damit gerechnet aber jetzt sind wir
vorbereitet wir haben ja auch eine
politik die sofort gestoppt hat und stop
and go in einer sekunde sozusagen
miteinander versucht zu vereinen also
die rettungsschirme kommen anders als
bei der euro rettung in derselben
sekunde wo wir abgeschaltet haben das
ist eine neue situation damals haben wir
erst die krise erst runter dann hat die
politik gehalten jetzt wird in derselben
sekunde werden die joysticks beide in
die hand genommen jetzt muss man aber
einen plan haben auch sozusagen wie man
die maschine wieder hochfährt in welcher
reihenfolge sind erst die schüler dran
die studenten was machen wir mit den
kleinen gewerbetreibenden die krise
trifft nicht alle gleichermaßen
und auch dass sie haben den punkt
gemacht dieses virus betrifft alle steht
auf der zeichnung das stimmt überhaupt
nicht
das virus hat sozial sehr
unterschiedliche verteilungswirkungen am
ende der nahrungskette weltweit sie
haben sie auch angesprochen wird tote
geben bei einer weltwirtschaftskrise die
möglicherweise sehen werden die menschen
die keine gesundheitsversicherung haben
in amerika in chicago
aber eben auch in vietnam und sonstwo
tatsächlich hinten runter fallen nicht
nur in deutschland und da aber auch s
bahn genauso vermeiden und er das muss
man die kalkulation für mich mit rein
wir können nicht nur auf unsere
todeszahlen in unseren kliniken schauen
sondern wir müssen auch schauen wenn wir
global denkende menschen sind was was
lösen wir da bitteschön aus da ist
politik glaube ich
muss verantwortlich gemacht werden und
eben nicht nur für deutschland
was tun es wieder die frage an herrn
felbermayr vielleicht könnten herr
felbermayr gesucht wird eben eine exit
strategie
vielleicht könnten ökonomen ja viel mehr
und für ausführlicher jetzt mit
virologen diskutieren die genau auch
darüber schon nachdenken oder mit den
berühmten modellieren
die physiker sind und versuchen eben
genau präzise wenn auch auf einer noch
nicht so festen datenbasis zu berechnen
welche strategie diejenige wer die uns
am meisten hilft der vollkommen richtig
und wir sind auch im gespräch ich sagen
kann das sagen für das ist so der
weltwirtschaft in kiel aber sicher auch
für alle kollegen wir reden mit den
epidemiologen und mit dem virologen das
große problem dass wir beide haben
sowohl die mediziner als auch die
ökonomen ist die datenbasis ihr müsst
mir sehr viel bessere information
darüber haben wie stark der durchsuchung
starts der bevölkerung schon ist der
über die anteile der menschen die schon
immunisiert sind über die anteile die
den virus in sich tragen
und da brauchen wir schnell sehr viel
bessere information wenn wir die nicht
haben
dann hilft das ganze arbeiten mit
modellen nichts wir müssen die modelle
ja kalibriert wie wir sagen also mit
daten aus der realität einreichen
und da ist unsere große forderung nicht
nur eine sondern der ganzen wissenschaft
eigentlich die evidenzbasierte arbeiten
wir wir brauchen mehr testen wir
brauchen mehr daten und wenn wir das
haben dann können wir auch mehr
beitragen
zu der frage wie können wir sozusagen
die volkswirtschaft zumindest wieder ein
teil möglichst schnell flott kriegen so
dass wir diesen zielkonflikt lösen
können wir wollen ja die vorgaben die
notwendig sind um die bevölkerung zu
schützen einheiten aber die ökonomischen
kosten minimieren und das geht nicht
ohne sehr viel mehr daten die politik
muss jetzt glaube ich geld in die hand
nehmen um eine große test infrastruktur
aufzubauen und sie musste überlegen
welche rechtlichen anpassungen sind
notwendig um diesen um diesen ausstieg
oder den einstieg in den ausstieg
vorzubereiten
zum beispiel im datenschutz
es ist interessant dass sie es andeuten
ein land gilt momentan sozusagen als
role model da ist ein lock down wie man
sagt vermieden worden erstens mit
wahnsinnig vielen tests zweitens dadurch
dass die menschen alle einen mundschutz
tragen und mit handys schauen wir mal
wie es ohne schatten und explodierende
infizierten zahlen geht zeigt südkorea
kein land hat so intensiv getestet
der staat kontrolliert bei handy-app
kontaktpersonen und infizierte und
stellt sie unter quarantäne
der großteil der bevölkerung lebt normal
weiter nur eben mit atemmasken und durch
getestet in südkorea haben wir gerade
gehört gibt es mit den handy apps die
möglichkeit identifizierte zu benennen
und auch deren kontaktpersonen das
diskutieren wir tatsächlich auch neben
den tests die wir viel mehr brauchen
robert habeck sagt heute er könne sich
so etwas vorstellen diese app gibt es
auch schon die heißt ich habe es könnte
sich das vorstellen wenn es freiwillig
ist was sagt der unternehmer ich will
die diskussion in deutschland
erstaunlich
wir sind in eine völlig ungewöhnliche
notsituation ich glaube die bedrohung
ist wirklich jedem klar
und ich finde es fast schon ein luxus
über das eine oder andere datenschutz
modell zu diskutieren da sind wir bei
den handlungsfeldern gesundheit auf der
einen seite und sag ich mal
freiheitsrechte auf der anderen seite
ich sehe überhaupt kein problem dabei
handy tracking zu benutzen
nicht nur anonymous handy tracking für
einen zeitlich klar begrenzten zeitraum
mit einem ganz klar begrenzten im
auftrag für einen ganz klar begrenzten
zweck und ich bin überzeugt davon dass
der großteil der deutschen bevölkerung
das begeistert aufnehmen würde die
technik steht zur verfügung und kann in
wenigen tagen eingesetzt werden nicht
die politik herr scholz was sagen sie
darüber nachgedacht wurde schon das
wissen wir
ist es möglich ist so etwas auch in
deutschland zu machen
es wird intensiv daran gearbeitet eine
technische plattform zu entwickeln die
das möglich macht dass viele freiwillig
daran teilnehmen können wo war ich mal
davon ausgehen würde dass das zu ziehen
jeder machen würde
für die dinge die wir brauchen die
notwendigen daten vermitteln und diese
diskussion wird jetzt ganz ganz zügig
geführt und das geht da zugleich um eine
technische entwicklung wie auch darum
dass überall durchsetzbar zu machen und
mein eindruck ist wenn wir das
hinbekommen können dass mit der
zustimmung fast der ganzen bevölkerung
so was dann eingeführt wird freiwillig
mit all den notwendigen datenschutz
vorkehrungen dann glaube ich wird das
auch funktioniert vizekanzler von dollar
gesteigert
ich war skeptisch ich finde wir nicht
missverstehen wir haben das mindeste
nicht hinbekommen die
desinfektionsmittel
die atemschutzmasken viele sachen die in
korea eben laufen also wirklich wenn man
so will folgt jener war dieses virus ist
kein lebendes lebewesen und da springt
nicht das stimmt nicht
das bewegt sich hier nicht über die
tischplatte das ist wie herr kekulé der
virologe sagt ein relativ stumpfes
instrument oder er sagt dass tickt wie
ein uhrwerk
man kann das mit hygiene maßnahmen die
wir jetzt ja versuchen halt mit einander
bekämpfen gleich wenn man das eine nicht
gedopt bekommt
fangen wir sozusagen bei bürger und
menschenrechten an immer freiwillig und
auf begrenzte zeit der soli begrenzte
zeit hat helmut kohl überleben es kann
ja sein weil wir weil wir einen dingen
nicht so gut hinbekommen haben so eine
andere gute sagen ich bin einfach nicht
so großzügig wie sie oder wir auch mit
dem weg geben mit dem weg geben dieser
freiheitsrechte weil das mit dem
zeitlich befristet oft ebenso nicht ich
mein misstrauen gegenüber dem staat dem
tod nichts bösartiges zu aber eine große
bequemlichkeit der soli wie gesagt
existiert noch heute helmut kohl der
erfinder ist ist schon von uns gegangen
der soli lebt noch auch diese ausnahme
dinge das haben wir ja nur 2021 befasst
also diskutieren sie nicht werden
sondern fragen noch mal ist das größere
problem dass wir immer noch um die tests
bringen und um die atemschutzmaske
ringen oder ist es tatsächlich eine
schlaue idee frau wagen also für einen
zeitraum iks ja das problem ist in 100
shows digitalen zeitalter alles was
einmal gespeichert ist gespeichert ist
und das ist natürlich schon ein problem
ich hätte nichts einzuwenden das auf
freiwilliger basis zu machen aber ich
habe etwas dagegen dass das jetzt als
das general modell also ich habe alles
was ich gelesen habe ich bin ja
nur laie wie wir wahrscheinlich in
medizinischer hinsicht alle die wir hier
sitzen aber ist zb sind die schutzmasken
tatsächlich viel elementarer was die
übertragung des virus angeht darüber ein
dass man schon dass uns das tollste
tracking nützt ja gar nichts wenn
trotzdem der virus sich weiter extrem
ausbreitet und deswegen fände ich es
jetzt wesentlich wichtiger dass wir mal
zu sehen dass wir in deutschland eine
ausreichende schutzkleidung bekommen wir
haben sie aktuell noch nicht mal fürs
medizinische personal für die pfleger
und wir müssten sie eigentlich jedem zur
verfügung stellen da wäre ich zum
beispiel dann auch dafür wirklich zu
verpflichten also dass keiner mehr
öffentlich sich bewegen darf ohne
schutzmaske nur da müssen die menschen
eine bekommen und nicht irgendwelchen
wucherpreisen bei amazon sondern
wirklich das müsste dann zur verfügung
gestellt werden und die kapazitäten da
zeigt sich eben wieder dass sich auch
globalisierung rächen kann also was ist
verlagert worden wird jetzt in
niedriglohn gebeten vor allem auch in
china produziert wir haben keine
kapazitäten mehr und wir müssen gucken
dass wir solche elementaren dinge auch
wieder selbst produzieren die schweiz
zum beispiel hat tatsächlich voll
automatisierte maschinen eingekauft und
produziert jetzt diese hochsicherheits
schutzmasken so und ähnliches müssen wir
im grunde auch machen weil das sind
einfach finde ich die viel viel
wichtigeren dinge und das andere kann
man auch machen aber nach meinem gefühl
würde das die freiheit nicht in stress
jedoch ich bin ja weitgehend
diese grundsätzlichen missstände bin ich
bin ich völlig bayern außer bei dem
thema das sie global sind unsere schuld
ist aber es geht darum dass eine zu tun
ohne das andere zu lassen
wir sind in einer exponentiellen
situation es geht nicht darum mit
seriell eine gute idee nach der anderen
abarbeiten oder es geht darum dass wir
parallel intelligent und differenziert
eine ganze reihe von maßnahmen
gleichzeitig auf den weg bringen
natürlich brauchen wir machen natürlich
brauchen die schutzkleidung natürlich
brauchen wir mehr testen noch mehr
testen und natürlich brauchen wir
tracing jeder dieser faktoren reduziert
die ansteckungsfähigkeit um iks prozent
und je mehr diese faktoren der
gleichzeitigen einsatz bringen desto
schneller reduzieren wir die
ansteckungsfähigkeit und das ist der
ganze entscheidende parameter
ich würde sagen wir lassen es bei diesen
gespaltenen bild
in der debatte es sei denn er schaut sie
ich will einfach nur sagen ich glaube
auch die richtige lösung ist jetzt alles
gleichzeitig zu machen was geht und was
wir garantiert und da sind wir uns auf
den weg zu bringen mit grossem einsatz
noch mit großen finanziellen einsatz und
es ist peinlich genug dass ein land wie
deutschland an einen weg artikeln
scheitert oder wenigstens bisher
scheitert sein
wir müssen und wollen noch mal sehen
wann kommen die masten das interessiert
doch das ist doch viel wichtiger als ein
handy tracking also design es ist gleich
wichtig das ist gleich wichtig sagen die
alle seiten es gibt jetzt einen
wachsenden zulauf aus den
internationalen stellt quellen die jetzt
stattfinden da ist der
gesundheitsminister ganz intensiv
hinterher und das macht auch sehr gut
nicht dass man ja sagen darf und
gleichzeitig ist es so dass wir auch
darüber nachdenken bestimmte dinge
hierzulande herzustellen wobei ja zu den
wahrheiten gehört manche dinge die ganz
wichtig sind für das was jetzt getan
werden muss werden sehr viel in
deutschland hergestellt zum beispiel
beatmungsgeräte da sind wir ziemlich
bedeutend immer diesen augen hat diese
masken und die masken brauchen und wir
haben maschinen die es leider nur in
china gibt auch wenn wir wenigstens den
pool für die basken haben das haben wir
schon gelernt in einer sendung die wir
am donnerstag gemacht habe wir schauen
nach den usa ist hoch interessant was
sich in den vereinigten staaten tut auch
da sind die bilder nicht
[Musik]
geisterstadt new york der big apple
macht dicht
die krankenhäuser sind überlastet die us
armee schickt ein lazarettschiff
vorsorglich werden zelte für die leichen
errichtet
weit über drei millionen erstanträge auf
arbeitslosenhilfe im märz historischer
nachkriegsrekord zur jahresmitte rechnen
experten mit über elf prozent
arbeitslosigkeit
manche halten bis jahresende gar 30
prozent für möglich das wäre schlimmer
als die große depression 1929
[Musik]
erst hat er verharmlost und zeit
verloren
jetzt soll das gigantische hilfspaket
von über 2.000 milliarden dollar
die us wirtschaft und vor allem trumps
wiederwahl retten
und schon nach ostern verspricht der
präsident eine weitgehende rückkehr zur
normalität
wir müssen zurück an die arbeit unsere
menschen wollen wieder arbeiten
dies ist ein land das dinge anpackt ich
glaube es wird ziemlich schnell zu weit
sei es dann soll alles schon wieder
vorbei sein herr felbermayr wenn donald
trump tatsächlich im alleingang wieder
öffnet theoretische frage wenn er
tatsächlich wieder eröffnet setzt er
damit europa zusätzlich unter druck
ich glaube europa sollte sich nicht
unter druck setzen lassen von diesen
us-präsidenten ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das eine gute idee ist
einen tages zu verkünden und zwar ganz
unabhängig davon was die epidemiologen
sagen oder dass die ausbreitung des
virus angeht
wirtschaftlich ist es ja auch so dass
die usa für uns zwar der wichtigste
exportmarkt sind nach nach wie vor
gleichzeitig aber ist es wichtiger dass
europa funktioniert die eurozone ist
insgesamt die gesamtzahl der länder dort
wichtiger als die usa das ist für uns
jetzt glaube ich viel bedeutet dass wir
die hausaufgaben zu hause machen dass
wir schauen dass europa auf die beine
kommt dass wir in europa keine
staatsschulden krise kriegen dass die
banken stehen da gibt es viele viele
dinge ich glaube an der stelle ist
sollte uns interessieren wird die usa
machen aber wir sollten uns nicht über
die maßen beeindrucken lassen von einem
präsidenten der vielleicht eine eine
entscheidung trifft nach
ist dir sehr bald wieder zurücknehmen
muss wenn nämlich die solche sich weiter
ausbreiten sollte da das virus ist
international die gegenmaßnahmen sind es
nicht die sind national die usa legen 1
2 billionen us dollar hilfspaket auf
unsere zahl haben wir schon genannt
wenigstens 750 milliarden kurze frage an
den experten woher haben wir das geld
wird es gedruckt zunächst einmal macht
der staat neue schulden oder 56
milliarden euro neuverschuldung geplant
jetzt für das jahr 2020 diese schulden
kommen sozusagen aus den ersparnissen
die bürger allerdings ist es auch so
dass die europäische zentralbank immer
höhere anteile der staatsschulden hält
auch der deutschen
und das bedeutet dann im endeffekt ja
anteil dieser schulden wird monetisieren
das ist nichts das man zu sagen
ordnungspolitisch gut findet jeden fall
ist in deutschland nicht ich auch nicht
aber faktum haben wir das haben wir das
schon in europa damit sind wir
unmittelbar beim bundesfinanzminister
herr scholz bleiben sie bei ihrem nein
zu gemeinsamen anleihen egal ob man die
jetzt eurobonds oder bewohner bonds
nennen bleiben sie dabei das ist keine
eurobonds geben soll
starten sie mir einmal noch mal zu sagen
dass ich total entsetzen über das was
sich aus den usa haben von dem
amerikanischen präsidenten anhöre
sie haben uns den film hier eben
eingespielt als mitmensch muss man sich
sorgen machen um die amerikaner denn
wenn das so durchgezogen wird dann wird
das konsequenzen haben für leben und
gesundheit unglaublich viele menschen
und deshalb bin ich auch mit dem
felbermayr völlig einer meinung dass
wird sich gar nicht durchhalten lassen
denn auch in den usa wird man die bilder
dann sehen die das ergebnis einer
solchen typischen strategiesitzung
konkret zu ihrer frage ja wir müssen
europa zusammenhalten und haben das auch
in mehreren schritten schon getan und
werden das weiter tun
erster punkt wir haben gesagt es braucht
eine koordinierte strategie so was
ähnliches was wir machen sollen die
anderen auch machen
zweiter punkt wir haben gestattet das
jetzt in dieser situation die regeln für
staatsschulden die die einzelnen länder
haben nicht gelten sondern dass jeder
die notwendigen kredite aufnehmen kann
um seine bürger und die wirtschaft zu
schützen dritter punkt wir haben gesagt
die regeln über beihilfe und
wettbewerbsregeln zu beachten müssen wir
nicht mehr so streng sehen wir können
unternehmen helfen auch wenn das im
wettbewerb dann staatshilfe ist weil das
jetzt dringend notwendig ist vierter
punkt wir haben gesagt ich soll mal
geguckt werden was ist im haushalt der
eu
fünfter punkt wir haben gesagt wir
wollen dass die europäische
investitionsbank so was ähnliches macht
wir unsere förderbank in deutschland die
kaffee und sind auch bereit ihr die
möglichkeit zu verschaffen noch mehr zu
tun und ersetzte punkt wir haben ein
system das exakt auf diese situation
vorbereitet ist und dass wir jetzt
schalten müssen
das ist der europäische
stabilitätsmechanismus da sind über 80
milliarden eingezahlt wer hat einen
verleih kapazität von über 500
milliarden alles zusammengerechnet mit
dem können wir jetzt so was ähnliches
wie spezielle rechte einzelner länder
bis zu einer bestimmten grenze auch dort
gewissermaßen sich geld zu besorgen
schaffen
und wenn man das alles zusammenrechnet
dann kommt man da schnell bei denen die
das wahrscheinlich machen werden auf
eine summe die jetzt im ersten anlauf
wahrscheinlich auch zügig 100 milliarden
euro umfassen kann also europäische
solidarität gehören den europäischen
rettungsschirm und dann haben sie
natürlich gelesen was sigmar gabriel
gesagt hat wenn wir uns nicht um 150
milliarden sondern 160 milliarden
verschuldet hätten und den italienern
und in spanien die in einer viel
schlechteren lage sind als wir fünf
milliarden gegeben hätte die hätten das
über hundert jahre nicht vergessen ich
glaube wir machen genau das wenn wir das
mit dem europäischen
stabilitätsmechanismus machen denn exakt
so funktionierte aber ohne dass wir
jetzt irgend ein einzelnes land
privilegieren sondern alle länder des
euros haben dann die möglichkeit darauf
zurückzugreifen und da geht es schon um
40 milliarden für einzelne länder die
ihnen helfen können in dieser situation
klarzukommen
ich glaube das ist eine dekorative war
der mann nicht mit wie soll ich das eher
mit überschriften arbeiten darf sondern
da muss man zb zur kenntnis nehmen dass
wir als lehrer aus der letzten
finanzkrise so eine starke kampfmaschine
wie den esm geschaffen haben
wir haben das lehre aus der finanzkrise
geschaffen und deswegen ist eben nicht
genau zugeschnitten auf das was wir
jetzt erleben nämlich auch eine pandemie
all die instrumente die sogenannte all
diese namen sind sehr gut und sehr
wichtig und ich glaube dass europa
bisher wesentlich stärker gehandelt hat
als wir es in der öffentlichkeit
wahrnehmen
dennoch sind corona eurobonds die
insbesondere die länder italien und
spanien unterstützen noch mal eine
andere liga sie sind schon symbolisch
eine andere liga und sie sind lange
genug in der politik um zu wissen wie
wichtig symbolik ist die italiener und
die spanier wollen keine almosen das
liegt auch er gabriel völlig falsch
sondern die wollen eine europäische
solidarität im haftungsverbund von
eurobonds
und wenn man diese krone eurobonds vom
betrag vom zweck von der lauft wenn wir
sie klar begrenzt und definiert dann
schaffen auch nicht den viel
gefürchteten präzedenzfall in die
europäische gemeinschaft zu schulden ist
aber vielleicht ein bisschen
widersprechen weil ich glaube es gehört
ein bisschen dazu dass unsere diskussion
sich losgelöst von dem worüber wir
konkret reden können also der
europäische der europäischen
stabilitätsmechanismus bedeutet dass wir
eine gemeinsame kreditaufnahme haben
exakt das was sie fordern dass es
möglich ist das gewissermaßen mit der
garantie die wir als deutsche geben und
ein paar andere länder es möglich ist
sich auch in einer schwierigen situation
mittel zu beschaffen und das ist in
wahrheit gar kein großer unterschied nur
etwas das funktioniert ja wir haben sie
lichtbedingungen und das ist das problem
also deswegen haben wir zum beispiel
italien und andere länder schon gesagt
sie wollen nicht unter den esm weil die
erfahrung besagt sie sind dann nicht
mehr herr ihrer eigenen politik und
werden zum beispiel jetzt die schlimmen
bilder aus spanien sehen spanien hat
natürlich unter dem druck der
sparauflagen auch sein gesundheitssystem
radikal schrumpfen müssen
ich sage ja ich sage ja auch nicht dass
wir jetzt sozusagen plötzlich die alle
schulden vergemeinschaften de facto ist
es ja jetzt schon so die europäische
zentralbank kauft staatsanleihen und
zwar der verschiedenen länder weil es
geht ja eigentlich nur um ein einziges
problem es geht um das problem dass
diese länder anders als deutschland
nicht mal eben zum kapitalmarkt gehen
können und sich das holen was sie
aktuell brauchen weil schon letzte woche
die zinsen massiv gestiegen sind
daraufhin hatte
wie gesagt wir kaufen die anleihen
dadurch hat man jetzt die zinssituation
entspannt aber man wenn man ehrlich ist
läuft es eigentlich darauf hinaus dass
die ezb in dieser krise die staaten
finanziert und ich finde in einer
solchen krise wie der jetzigen ist das
absolut richtig das könnte man dann aber
auch dadurch verändern dass man gar
nicht den umweg über den finanzmarkt und
die spekulation geht weil es ist ja die
spekulation die die zinsen hoch treibt
sondern einen direkten mechanismus macht
dann hätte man keine gemeinsame schulden
haftung und die staaten würden das geld
bekommen was sie aktuell brauchen weil
auch wir hier in deutschland sind
unmittelbar betroffen wenn sich in
italien das finanzsystem zusammenbricht
und das finanzsystem ist äußerst fragil
das ist ja nicht stabil
das ist seit der letzten krise im grunde
einen desolaten zustand
weil auch italien überhaupt ja nicht aus
der krise herausgekommen ist auch wegen
sparauflagen nicht zuletzt also insoweit
wäre das eine ehrlichere strategie
gewesen sich weiter an ohne chance
ob sie nicht auch der auffassung sind
dass die ezb gleich direkt helfen könnte
herr scholz vorher will ich es aber noch
von herrn felbermayr wissen noch mal die
frage an sie herr felbermayr wenn die
ezb am ende sowieso und die spanischen
und italienischen anleihen aufkauft weil
sie niemand haben will kann sie da nicht
eigentlich auch sofort direkt helfen
im prinzip ist das was ist das genau das
was bis jetzt nur ist das
ordnungspolitisch nicht die richtige
antwort wir sollten die ezb nicht weiter
überlasten
indem sie mit ihrem geldpolitischen
mandat die hausaufgaben macht die die
europäischen staaten nicht selber machen
wollen ich glaube es geht es darum die
schwächeren länder in der eurozone mit
den finanzmitteln auszustatten die sie
brauchen um genug zu tun
gesundheitspolitisch genug zu tun aber
auch für die wirtschaft genug zu tun und
grund durch diese krise zu kommen das
sind fiskal politisches thema und da
sollten wir jetzt nicht die ezb zwingen
ihr mandat wieder zu überschreiten weil
die nationalen regierungen nicht in der
lage sind etwas aufzugleisen mit hohen
symbolcharakter herausgehen richtig
gesagt hat dass sehr viel wirksamer wäre
noch wichtiger wäre aus
ordnungspolitischen
perspektiven und europa oder bauwerken
wichtig einschränkung dass das
eingeschränkt sein ist das ist
eingeschränkt sein muss das ist es
natürlich weil wir sind in einer
ausnahmesituation dabei steingart haben
wir zu wenig solidarität mit den anderen
ich glaube mittlerweile hat sich da eine
balance gefunden und in der tat über die
europäischen institutionen die dafür
vorgesehen sind wird geordnet die ezb
ist ja wenn man so will eine große
hilfsorganisation geworden
zur rettung wir sind in einem
permanenten rettungsmodell deswegen
würde ich schon gerne
ich meine das sagen alle immer jetzt ist
krise jetzt dürfen wir darüber nicht
reden aber wir haben in der griechenland
krise in der euro krise in der
lehman-krise nie darüber gesprochen was
ist eigentlich mit europa insgesamt los
die wettbewerbsfähigkeit von italien von
unseren banken system wo ist die
deutsche bank war sie mit thyssenkrupp
eigentlich passiert wo steht siemens
warum wird ein einziges unternehmen in
den usa höher bewertet als alle 30 dax
konzerne
das heißt ich will sagen dieses land
steigt strukturell und relativ zu den
anderen ab drei länder sind im übrigen
aus der krise fast raus das ist japan
das südkorea und das ist china
da war es auch eigentlich asien wir
müssen eine grundsätzlichere diskussion
glaube ich führen als die wir nur retten
retten retten was ist die substanz von
dem was wir retten
ich sage unter diesen rettungsschirm
schrumpft der kern vom kern dessen was
italien ausgemacht hat und erst was
deutschland ausgemacht hat und deswegen
sollten wird diese krise auch nutzen
tatsächlich nicht alle sind jetzt nur
virologen geworden wo der rettungs
manager sondern wir müssen die
verbleibende rest energie zusammennehmen
glaube ich und über die zeit danach
positiv denken und strukturiert denken
was wir für karrieren haben wie
deutschland hochkommen kann unabhängig
von staatlichen hilfsprogrammen die
jetzt notwendig sind die uns aber nicht
retten
also sie haben völlig recht hier steigen
habe wahrscheinlich nur wir sollten
unterscheiden zwischen wichtig und
dringend die diskussion die sie jetzt
führen wollen ist wichtig aber ja nicht
dringend natürlich müssen wir über die
substanz dessen reden was am ende des
tages retten wollen im augenblick
scheint mir aber sehr viel wichtiger
dass wir über ganz ganz schnelle und
über solidarische finanzierungsmittel
entscheiden und ich kann nicht verstehen
dass gegen eurobonds
spricht und die wahrnehmung dass die eu
mittlerweile sozusagen ausgeglichen
agiert mag unsere hier sein
in italien ist eine völlig andere die
diskussion in italien nach dem treffen
wird oder nach der video kommt von der
27 regierungschefs wo deutschland
österreich und holland aktiv gegen
euro-bonds argumentiert haben ist
katastrophal so dass selbst die alle
gemäßigten die präsident materieller
mittlerweile in seiner rede an die
nation auf die eu und insbesondere auf
deutschland weist und sagt ihr fehlt die
solidarität und wenn dann nachher wieder
salvini gewählt wird und sagen
anschließend netten italiener menschen
die machen diesen guten wein und die
tolle pizza und wählen sie soll wenige
kann das sein aber es bleibt doch nur
ein anderer name für einen kredit
finanziertes programm insofern ob dieses
eurobond corona
es sind kredite und sie helfen sozusagen
dieses feuer europa zu löschen
und wir fragen noch mal olaf scholz
eurobonds ja oder nein bleiben sie bei
ihrem nein ich bleibe beim jahr zum esm
da geht es um richtig viele zig
milliarden wahrscheinlich weit über 100
milliarden
und ich will ausdrücklich dazu sagen das
ist eine hilfe die sofort mobilisiert
werden kann und die eine riesige wirkung
hat und auch kann ich persönlich bin der
meinung dass es nicht richtig ist jetzt
eine strukturelle debatte zu führen noch
mal die kühlanlagen dass es auch mal
direkt gerne aber direkt in sonst müssen
sie noch eine chance wahren führen wir
die debatte ist nie die richtige haben
wir uns nachher darüber unterhalten aber
ich will ausdrücklich sagen ein großer
fehler in der letzten finanzkrise war
ist dass wir den anderen so moralisch
begegnet sind
das finde ich war völlig unakzeptabel
und das darf jetzt nicht wieder
passieren ich finde wer jetzt den
ländern die in schlimmster not sind
irgendwelche vorhaltungen macht wie sie
schon immer waren und was weiß ich der
handelt nicht nur nicht solidarisch und
auch völlig unvernünftig da bin ich
völlig bringt und deshalb sage ich ja
wir müssen was tun mit der ezb und wir
müssen was tun ganz in großem umfang in
dem wir helfen mit einer gemeinsamen
kreditaufnahme das ist mit dem esm
verbunden das weiß nur nicht jeder
und ich bin mit frau wagenknecht der
meinung das will ich ausdrücklich dazu
sagen dass das natürlich nur
funktioniert wenn wir jetzt nicht mit
jedem land über einzelne bedingungen
verhandeln sondern wenn wir sagen das
ist jetzt wegen corona und das gibt es
einfach jetzt unter diesem raum
die bedingungen existieren ja also
deswegen hat ja gesagt wenn wir unter
den esm geben dann wird gleich savigny
gewählt weil die leute sagen existieren
dafür bin ich ja zuständig das zu
verhindern
und da können sie mir vertrauen wenn sie
an der strecke als auch europa sein ich
will ja nur dass sie sich die hintertür
noch offen halten legen sie sich nicht
zu sehr fest halten sie sich den lasse
mich einmal milliarden schwer helfen und
freuen sich erst mal darüber dass das
wirkt wir reden genau jetzt darüber herr
scholz nicht um ihnen einen gefallen zu
tun sondern weil es unbedingt wichtig
ist noch mal nach deutschland zu schauen
nicht nur großen unternehmen soll
geholfen werden sondern natürlich auch
klein- und mittelständischen unternehmen
da ist die richtige kamera und ich
möchte ihnen gerne einen mann vorstellen
der aus hamburg in unser studio gekommen
ist er hat 13 modegeschäfte in hamburg
heißt martin heldmann und ist heute bei
uns hängen schön dass sie da sind harald
heldmann 13 geschäfte in hamburg 80
mitarbeiter insgesamt und diese 13 läden
mussten sie jetzt schließen die hin sind
alle geschlossen zur zeit wir haben 50
verkaufs mitarbeiter in die kurzarbeit
geschickt und wir haben natürlich im
moment das problem dass wir eben halt
weiterhin der verpflichtungen sind
unsere mieten für die zeit der laden
schließung zu zahlen
darüber hinaus haben wir in der
textilbranche das fiel auch eben halt
zum ende viel größere problem das wir
eigentlich eine saison eben halt immer
betrachten saison bedeutet wir haben
halbjährliche zyklen und wir sind am
anfang der saison unsere läger sind voll
und wir haben keinen cash flow
dadurch sind die konnten relativ leer
und sie haben sie gerade fragen haben
sie schon auf ihrem konto unterstützung
gefunden staatshilfen gefunden
im moment haben natürlich noch nicht
gefunden wir haben kurzarbeitergeld
beantragt
aber ich weiß nicht ob diese zahl stimmt
ich höre 800.000 anträge sind gestellt
worden
das wird eine gewisse zeit dauern dieses
geld fließt und die geschäfte die
brauchen im moment cashflow das bedeutet
cash is king und wir können nur dann
überleben wenn wir eben halt darüber
hinaus eben halt diese unterstützung
kommt sie haben natürlich auch viele
lieferanten kommen die ihnen jetzt
entgegen manche von denen leiden
logischerweise auch können sie sich mit
ihren lieferanten einigen wir einigen
uns mit den lieferanten viele
lieferanten kommen und in der tat
entgegen und geben uns zahlungsziele
verlängerte zahlungsziele von 30 bis
zusätzlich 60 tagen
es gibt je nachdem wie die lieferanten
aufgestellt sind eben halt aber auch
welche die das eben halt nur
zähneknirschend tun können
das ist sicherlich ein problem aber das
hauptproblem wird ja erst kommen wenn
die neue winterware geliefert wird den
herbst winter saison ansteht das wird im
august september sein wird es eben halt
zu einem noch viel größeren crash kommen
die insolvenzwelle im einzelhandel hat
ja schon eingesetzt
sie wird dann aber ein zweites mal mit
voller wucht einsetzen weil dann eben
halt herbst winterware nicht bezahlt
werden kann weil schlicht und ergreifend
die sommerware richtig umgesetzt hat es
konnten keine rücklagen neu gebildet
werden kann ihnen ihr onlineshop helfen
sie haben 30 mitarbeiter die online
arbeiten wir ja das sind 20 mitarbeiter
der rest ist eben halt auch zum teil in
einer verwaltung im großhandel tätig der
onlineshop hilft aber eigentlich aufwand
er kann das nicht auffangen weil dafür
ist der anteil eben halter umsätze die
online erwirtschaften würde deutlich
klar
ausgerechnet große ketten wie da ich man
beispielsweise oder auch adidas stellen
jetzt ihre mietzahlungen ein können sie
das wenn auch nur für einen monat können
sie das auch wir haben mit allen
vermietern gesprochen und haben ähnliche
vereinbarungen auf ja zunächst stunden
vorbehaltlich
vielleicht eventueller gesetzliche
lösungen getroffen sind aber nicht so
sicher dass die kommen das problem bei
der miete ist dass es den letzten
vorhandenen cashflow ja ich sage jetzt
mal vernichtet weil es kommt nichts
neues rein wir kriegen keine neuen cash
flow eben halt in die geschäfte hinein
und das wiederum führt dazu dass sich
die krise im moment im einzelhandel und
im insbesondere im textileinzelhandel
beschleunigt weil die geschäfte haben im
moment jahreszeitlich bedingt sehr wenig
geld auf dem konto
weil die eben halt früher sommer fahre
eben halt in guten geschäften weil das
kind bezahlt ist hat man toll dass wir
sie heute bei uns im studio hat mit
vielen lieben dank und ich marschiere
zurück in die runde natürlich genau mit
dieser frage
olaf scholz wand kommen firmen wie die
von harald man zu liquidität zu cash das
funktioniert seit kurzem ganz gut wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass der staat das
machen kann haben seit kurzer zeit auch
alle genehmigung der europäischen
kommission für unsere hilfen also bis zu
90 prozent abzudecken
wir haben mit allen sparkassen mit allen
raiffeisenbanken mit einem vereins
banken mit allen privaten banken
gesprochen dass sie das jetzt möglich
schneller umsetzen und versuchen alles
mögliche dass das auch in großem umfang
passiert wir gehen davon aus dass jetzt
in ganz kurzer zeit diese kredite auch
ausgereicht werden und wir deshalb für
liquidität sorgen können so nun
appellieren sie ich zitiere sie an die
banken und an die ämter und sie hoffen
noch einmal zitat dass sich das
herumspricht dass ist diesen
rettungsschirm gibt und ihr
milliardenprogramm gibt sie wissen schon
dass das bürokratische institutionen
sind
da stauen sich die anträge und manche
stellen irgendwie auch die
antragstellung ein wie hier in berlin
die investitionsbank die sich jetzt bei
45.000 anträgen nicht weiter auf
wartenummern verlegt sondern erst mal
dicht gemacht hat erstmal gibt es einmal
das liquiditätsprogramm dass wir schon
vor zwei wochen vorgestellt haben das
jetzt stück für stück mit den
genehmigungen der kommissionen auch um
werden dessen wo jetzt die liquidität
auch fließt und das glaube ich wird in
ganz kurzer zeit riesige summen aus
machen die da jetzt überall in die
unternehmen sich begeben
da geht es um kredite
die aber damit unbürokratisches von der
klassischen geschäftsbeziehung des
unternehmens gemacht wird so dass wir
teilweise ohne eigene prüfung die
rückdeckung dafür geben
das zweite sind die vielen
förderprogramme aller 16 länder wo wir
als bund jetzt auch etwas gemacht haben
seitdem der bundestag und bundesrat am
freitag endgültig das korps gegeben hat
können jetzt diese mittel überall
ausgegeben werden
einige länder haben schon vorher
angefangen man sieht ja an den rhein
auch berlin auch landen wo ich auch
verschiedene andere haben schon
angefangen um gewissermaßen das geld
schnell auszureichen und kriegen von uns
das dann wieder das geht jetzt ab sofort
los ich bin sicher da gibt es bestimmt
ganz ganz viele schwierigkeiten aber ich
habe gemerkt alle sind guten willens und
damit es nicht zu schwer wird haben wir
auch gesagt diese direkten zuschüsse die
ja in jedem land ein bisschen anders
sind aber immer so eine basis durch den
bund haben diese direkten zuschüsse
sollen so schnell wie möglich ausgezahlt
werden die müssen ganz schnell in
unternehmen arbeiten
ich meine das problem ist doch dass es
diese direkten zuschüsse außer in bayern
nur mit für unternehmen gibt bis zu 15
beschäftigten und alle die darüber sind
und das sind ja nicht alles hoch
profitable unternehmen mit wirklich also
risiken eigenkapital wo die banken hurra
rufen dass sie ihnen jetzt mehr kredit
geben dürfen sondern das sind ja
vielfach unternehmen die soll man zwar
solide gewirtschaftet haben aber eine
relativ schmale gewinnmarge haben und
nach dem was ich höre aus gesprächen aus
mails gibt es genügend wo die hausbank
schon ganz klar signalisiert hat allein
wegen dieser 10% haftung werden sie
keinen kredit ausreichen und es ist auch
fraglich ob diese betreffende
unternehmen eine zusätzliche
verschuldung wo ja nicht die
zusätzlichen einnahmen sind also im
restaurant wird nicht doppelt so viele
gäste haben dann wieder alles aufgeht
sondern das ist ja weg ob die das
irgendwann zurückzahlen könnten das
heißt sie werden keinen kredit bekommen
und ich höre sogar also schlimme
geschichten dass teilweise die zinsen
hoch gezogen wurden von den banken auch
für kontokorrentkredite und unternehmer
jetzt sagen ja ich es ja ich kriege gar
nichts von diesen hilfen ich habe mehr
als 15 beschäftigte ich kriege keinen
kredit ich habe hohe zinsen ich muss
jetzt eigentlich kurzarbeitergeld auch
mal voraus sagen weiß nicht wann das
zurückfließt das ist ja auch offen und
im grunde bin ich kurz vor der insolvenz
und wenn
dann lese dass jedes fünfte unternehmen
aktuell angst hat in die insolvenz zu
gehen dann muss man sagen da muss was
nachjustiert werden das reicht nicht das
reicht einfach nicht mehr häuschen